I still am a media
I'm almost one year not drinking man
that's crazy no sauce stop ringing boys
I really wish I only had three toes cuz
then I get a discount all pedicures
is that a deal in desert it sure is
except for people in the pedicure big
walk-in maybe like hose this I'm dissing
cuz he got toes missing hey hey hey hey
Rock asleep man's back for the 29
Peter's age beats all the trip and my
cousin Percy
yeah put the sleep mask in the bars come
out like some bars outside and the bar
is out what I'm in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you trippin if you ain't
think I'm spittin and I'm sayin same
[ __ ] but I say it all rhythm and I come
through the [ __ ] then you know I said
show yep get settle show Mom Buffy you
want my merged oh I say no mom [ __ ]
you want the perks give me the [ __ ]
bar
[Music]
[Music]
listen into the early morning at 7:00
a.m. gonna grab some stones go grab some
stones get my party on after the party
with of brassy styles I know Aquinas no
fish no dog no cats no hamsters no
llamas and get no monkeys nor an
arsonist no for lingos nose like office
and get no pets don't call the cops you
want to hear the way it handle works his
working process on music this is this is
how he develops music right here sports
sports sports the team synergy energy
energy energy that's a reference track
mousie
why because it blowed up people died a
lot of smoke in the sky
kinda like Vesuvius of Pompeii that was
a bad I'm a city boy
no birds won't stops city boy cops I
like variety different kinds of snacks
yeah I like it like time let me tell ya
the hype about that I ain't jokin I
enjoy them from the distance ain't
falling off that tall [ __ ] I can look at
the mountain and I can look and just be
like all [ __ ] but I don't wanna find me
to walk up on it I don't wanna be all on
those [ __ ] where I fell Huns of goddamn
boat and I gotta choose my arm from
other than wrong with me hey nothing
wrong with me I'm beatin my dick in the
privacy of my own home
he'll know what the [ __ ] beating his
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now but we just do that yeah that's how
we cover up that we're bad at interview
it
[Laughter]